Jan sagen dieses jahres hatten wir schon darüber berichtet ihnen macht, weltraum firma spacex mit der falcon 9 rakete
Habe das erste mal einen satelliten mit einer wieder verwendbaren antriebs rakete ins weltall geschickt jetzt will europa nachziehen
die europäische
weltraumorganisation esa entwickelt derzeit ein mehrfach verwendbarer raum fahrzeug der unbemannte space reiter soll schon, im jahr
2021 in die erdumlaufbahn fliegen und dann später wieder auf die erde
zurückkehren können was der space 3 da alles kann und ob europa damit tatsächlich
seine eigenständigkeit in der raumfahrt zurückerobern kann jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Am 30 november war es soweit die europäische
Weltraumagentur esa hat einen vertrag zum space rider unterschrieben der plan wird also konkret erst einmal geht es noch
Um die knapp 37 millionen euro schwere
Planungsphase doch danach soll es direkt an die umsetzung gehen der erste testflug vom space rider ist schon für 2021
Eingesetzt der konkrete plan space raider wird vom europäischen weltraumbahnhof in kourou zu seiner reise ins all aufbrechen
Das soll mit hilfe einer wg rakete passieren vega ist italienisch und steht für vito
europäer die
generationen avant sata also übersetzt, so etwas wie
fortgeschrittenen generation einer europäischen trägerrakete es handelt sich dabei
Um eine vierstufige trägerrakete für satelliten die im auftrag der esa entwickelt worden ist nach zwei monaten
im niedrigen erdorbit also einer
Höhe von etwa 400 kilometern soll ein modul des raumfahrzeuges wieder in die atmosphäre eintreten und dann möglichst sanft und
unbeschädigt auf der erde landen space weiter soll als labor fungieren mit dem experimente in der schwerelosigkeit
Getestet werden zudem sollen neue technologien aus formiert werden technisch gesehen basiert das projekt space rider auf dem
experimentellen raumfahrzeug die xv das steht für
Intermediate experimente wege seien testflug fand, im jahr 2015 statt danach
Landete es im pazifik und genau das ist der entscheidende punkt bisher hat europa mit der esa zwar das potenzial
Satelliten und so weiter ins all zu schicken der knackpunkt dabei ist aber sie wieder heil
Erde zu bringen damit hinkt europa tatsächlich weit hinterher mit dem space reiter will die esa also jetzt seine stellung in sachen weltraum know-how
raumfahrt ausbauen denn wir haben darüber berichtet die usa sind da unter anderem mit neuen akteuren auf dem markt ganz ganz vorne mit dabei
unter anderem eben auch ihren mast weltraum firma spacex vor allem im bereich der
Trägerraketen ist der kostendruck und auch der wettbewerb auf diesem markt enorm gestiegen schon im märz 2017 hat das basics
wiederverwendbare
weltraum flieger ins all gebracht und zwar erfolgreich die falcon 9 rakete
War tatsächlich sicher auf einer schwimmenden plattform, im atlantik gelandet nach. Maß hat die die entwicklung solcher
wiederverwendbaren antriebsraketen allerdings 15 jahre gedauert höchste zeit also für die esa
Nachzuziehen auch deswegen gab es wohl eine weitere
vertragsunterschrift von seiten der esa zusammen mit
Lv will die europäische, weltraumagentur sich um die optimierung der europäischen vega rakete kümmern und die pläne auf dem papier bezüglich
des pays reiter sind wahrhaftig optimistisch jedes raumfahrzeug soll
800 kilogramm transportieren können also fast eine tonne
jedes von ihnen soll sechsmal in den weltraum geschickt werden können pro flug werden dafür 40 millionen euro
kalkuliert nach angaben der esa gibt es auch schon
konkretes interesse an dem projekt beispielsweise von seiten der pharmaindustrie wenn er kein video zur weiteren entwicklung
Verpassen wollte das wird mir hier ein abo aufsaugen vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch immer über neue videos informiert hier geht es weiter mit und dafür draufklicken
neues zeitalter der raumfahrt eingeleitet neue space extraction
ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran